اكبر محطه لطاقه النوويه في اوروبا تنجو
من كارثه بعد تعرضها لقصف بوابل من
القذائف سقط بعضها بالقرب من المفاعلات
والحق اضرارا بمبنى لتخزين النفايات
المشعه
قال في اجتماع بباريس انه اجر اتصال
هاتفيا عاجلا على نظيره الاوكراني
تعاني منها من خلال التهديدات التي تلقي
بالثقلها على محطه توليد الكهرباء في
زبرجيا فمع كل انتصار عسكري لاوكرانيا
بدوره دعا رئيس الاوكراني في اعضاء حلف
شمال الاطلسي الى ضمان حمايه المنشات
النوويه من القصف الروسي
[تصفيق]
جميع دولنا حريصون على عدم الوقوع حوادث
خطيره في منشات النوويه نريد كلنا ان
يتوقف الارهابيون الروس عن قتل الناس
وتحتاج دولنا الى ضمانات لحمايه الصواريخ
الروسيه والتحرك لحمايه المنشات النوويه
من التخريب
من جهتها قالت روسيا ان قصف محطه سابورجيا
قد يؤدي الى حادث نوويه خطير وقررت
اتهامتها للقوات الاوكرانيه بانها
المسؤوله عن الهجمات
في انحاء العالم نفوذها لحمل القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على وقف اطلاق النار